Hello everybody!
Sorry, I'm like a mess right now.
I'm sorry,
I didn't realize.
I was like, okay, I still have three more minutes before the stream starts.
Let me go do this message real quick.
And then I was like typing my message out.
I was like, and like typing, like I had to answer some Discord work messages and an email.
And I looked at the clock.
I was like, oh my God, it's 5.01.
Oh my God, these messages will be so fast.
I can answer all of these before the stream starts.
And then now you guys might be wondering, wow, Doki, why didn't you prep those things before the stream started?
Huh?
Well, I have a perfectly good explanation for this.
I had Surefour message me and was like, hey, I saw that you're planning on streaming Deadlock.
Do you want like a quick crash course on like on how to play?
Because I know you're fucking miserable.
I'm like, yeah.
Yeah.
So, so like for an hour out, he was like teaching me how like, like he was teaching me a lot of stuff.
I was like, and by the way, that by the way, like I played four games of Deadlock.
By the way, like even before the crash course, my friends were like, hey, we'll also teach you how to play the game.
And then, and then the entire game, I was just like, I was just like, I don't know.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't know.
I'm just like, I'm like dying.
I'm like, I'm like, I'm getting, I'm getting cyber bullied in my life.
Like, what am I, what am I doing wrong?
And then we lost.
Obviously we lost.
And I was looking at, I was like looking at the score and then, and then it was like, I was like, obviously I had the lowest damage because I was chucked into this fucking MMR.
That was obviously higher than what I'm supposed to be in because my friends have been playing Deadlock.
But then like, since I'm grouped up with them, they chucked me into their MMR.
So I had 7k damage.
And it was, it was like a 50 minute, it was like an hour, a 55 minute game.
I had 7k damage.
And then the next person had 25k plus damage.
Like the second lowest damage was 25k.
I had 7k.
We had somebody at DC.
Um, in the middle of the game.
Um, and they still had more souls than me.
I'm just like...
And like after the game, after the game, I was like, I'm sorry guys for whining.
I'm sorry.
I just don't understand.
I just, I was like, I'm sorry bros.
I'm sorry guys.
I just, I just don't understand what is playing.
Every time I play, try to play Deadlock, I play a different character.
So like, um, so like, I don't know.
I think I was playing Haze today.
Today I was playing Haze.
And I was just like, I don't, I don't understand.
I just don't know.
I got thrown into the pack of wolves.
Anyway, yeah, it's like trial by fire.
They literally threw me into the middle of the swimming pool.
And was like, you're going to learn how to swim right now.
It's like the pool is like, like 20 feet deep.
And they just threw me in the middle of the pool.
It was like, all right, it's time to fucking play Deadlock.
Anyway, right after that.
I went into the crash course with Surefour.
And then he actually taught me a lot of stuff that I didn't know.
I was like, wait, what?
He's like, oh yeah, you should know about this.
Now that you've like played, you just played, right?
I was like, yeah.
He's like, oh yeah, you should know about this, right?
I was like, what?
You know, you should know about like how you can, you can slide and everything.
I was like, slide?
He's like, yeah, the movement tech, you know, dash slide.
I'm like, dash slide?
I knew about the dash.
I didn't know there was a slide part.
So anyway, I learned about...
Yeah, and then you can do dash jump slide.
I was like, dash jump slide?
There's, there's additional movement?
I was like, what is this?
I was like, wait, what is this?
It's in the official tutorial.
Guys, the last time I did the official tutorial.
Was in April.
Guys.
You guys, you can't fucking be like...
It was in the official tutorial.
The last time I looked at the tutorial.
Was in April when the game was first introduced as a closed beta.
When, when, when the game had no name.
The game literally had no name yet.
No official...
It wasn't even called Deadlock yet.
When I got to play for the first time.
So...
So yeah, anyway.
Like he...
And then he was like, yeah, play Abram.
I was like, why?
And he's like, you don't have to aim.
And I was like, oh, cool.
.
He's like, I was like, what do I play?
And he's like, play Abram.
And I'm like, oh, okay.
.
For real.
So the reason why...
I'll show you guys why.
I'll go into the training room.
Why, like, Abram is like the character to play.
Because literally, he was teaching me the combos for Abram.
And he's like, yeah, you're going to be playing against...
Obviously, you're going to be playing against other new players.
And like, noobs don't know how to parry.
Like, so you can abuse that shit.
So like, you know, you can...
You can give them a very hard time.
Yeah, and then there's like guides.
You can...
There's like guides.
And everything.
I like how somebody was like, there's a parry...
Look, see?
Some people have played this game.
And they're like, there's a parry?
Yes, apparently...
There's a parry.
That's what I'm saying.
Noobs don't know how to parry.
They don't know how to parry.
You can...
Exactly.
They don't teach you that.
They...
I told you.
That's like...
That's like Sherpa was like, yeah, you got it.
You should play it.
You should play Abram.
They don't...
He's like, yeah, no, you can abuse that shit.
Because fucking noobs don't know how to parry.
Anyway.
So...
So that's why...
That's why he told me to play Abram.
And he was like...
He was teaching me like, what to buy for Abram.
And like, what I can do to like, destroy noobs.
I bet you I'm gonna get destroyed.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get destroyed anyway.
Like, I feel like...
I feel like...
He teach...
He's gonna teach...
He taught me all of this.
Hoping I retain my knowledge.
I'm gonna give it to you guys straight.
I will be very surprised if like, I...
I don't crash out and burn in my first game.
I...
I'm gonna be...
I'm gonna be very surprised if I am not...
If I am not bottom everything at the end of the first game.
Another thing I like...
It was so painful.
I was like, why isn't there a surrender game?
And then apparently...
I was told that Valve does not put surrenders in any of their games.
Cause you suffer.
You have to suffer till the very end.
So...
This might be just like...
Who knows?
I might only play two games if I'm lucky.
Like...
Apparently Dota, after so many years, does not have a surrender button for Dota.
So...
We'll see how it goes.
We just gotta suffer, I guess.
Um...
But yeah.
Sorry.
I'm just charging my mouse right now.
I forgot to charge my mouse.
I was like...
Oh yeah.
Let's see.
Let's see how...
It's been a while since I charged my...
Uh...
G Pro...
Superlight.
Let's see how much battery I have left.
7%.
So that's...
That's what I'm doing right now.
I...
It's at...
I'll...
I'll use it at 40%.
So I'm just charging my mouse today.
Right now.
Like...
Legitimately.
Legitimately, it went from 7% to 38%.
Um...
And...
In 13 minutes.
So I feel like that's pretty fast.
Like...
It's...
It's pretty fast.
You know?
Like...
In...
In 13 minutes.
It's already at...
Almost at 40%.
So...
We're okay.
We're...
We're fu...
We're okay.
Um...
What else?
What else was I told to remember for...
Um...
What else was I told to remember about Deadlock?
Oh no.
I'm not retaining anything.
I'm...
But yeah.
Um...
Abrams...
The character Abrams is literally just a fighting game.
Like...
You're just punching people.
You don't have to shoot your gun.
You just...
His entire moveset and combos is just...
You brought...
You beat the shit out of people.
So like...
I hope...
I hope I play against enough...
I hope I actually am playing against noobs that are just like...
That are just as bad as the game as I am.
So I can take advantage to the...
To the part...
I hope I get...
I hope I get Abrams.
I swear to God.
I spent an hour fucking trying to learn Abrams.
I swear to fucking God.
I spent an hour trying to learn this character.
And if I do not get Abrams as a first pick...
I swear to fucking God.
After everything I've been through.
Getting...
I'm getting my shit beat in.
But I'm fucking sure for it.
That plays that game...
Like...
8 plus hours almost every day on stream.
Since April.
I swear to fucking God.
I'm gonna be so mad.
If my first game gets fucked over that fast.
Anyway...
This is literally my first MOBA.
This is my first MOBA game ever.
Which is why I have a lot of hate...
Towards MOBAs.
Because I don't understand.
Well...
Hate is a very strong word.
And I stand behind it.
And I...
I don't take it back.
Anyway...
No, I've not...
Never actually...
You guys are like...
What about Pokemon Unite?
Pokemon Unite is...
Is barely classified as a MOBA.
It's like a fucking...
It's like an iPhone game.
It's a fucking phone game.
It's literally a phone game.
Like it's not...
Oh my...
I'm sorry.
I know I like...
Did a fucking eSports thing.
Like a Twitch Rivals thing for Pokemon Unite.
But it...
It's such...
I barely...
It's like...
Baby's first MOBA.
I'm sorry.
I did a Twitch Rivals for Pokemon Unite.
But like...
I can't...
I can't see...
I don't categorize Pokemon Unite as same as like the shit I had to deal with in Deadlock.
Anyway...
Like I said...
A long time ago...
My friends back then...
Tried to teach me to play League.
I plugged in the...
I plugged in the first game they threw me in.
When I had to learn League.
And I was like...
Sorry.
My internet crashed.
That's literally...
I was just like...
Oh sorry.
My internet crashed.
Well...
Too bad.
I guess.
And then I never touched League again after that.
I managed to never have to touch League after that.
Anyway...
So why am I playing Deadlock?
If I had such a disdain for...
For MOBAs?
Well...
I keep being told by other FPS players.
Even though this is not an FPS game.
That...
This is gonna be the next big game.
And that...
If I learn...
To get...
If I finally learn MOBA mechanics.
Maybe...
I will change my mind.
I will have a character development.
And...
A character development arc.
And actually learn...
To love...
These types of games.
So...
I decided...
By sheer peer pressure.
Because I am very easily persuaded and manipulated into...
Because I...
Because I want people to...
I want to fit in...
In society.
I decided to try Deadlock again.
On stream.
So...
Here we are.
I want to fit in.
I want my peers to be like, Whoa!
That's right, girl!
Join us in Deadlock!
And I was like, Whoa!
I want to fit in the society!
And I also learned Deadlock like all the other cool players!
So here we are.
Trying it again.
And I remember... I'm trying... Oh my gosh.
What did they say?
They were like, Be careful.
It can change you.
Yeah.
Don't let the toxicity overtake you.
MOBAs change a person.
One of my friends was like, I was like, Oh no.
Let me see.
I'll show you guys the image you guys want to see in visual form.
So like, if I ever actually learn to love MOBAs, I can actually get even more toxic, which is crazy to think about.
So if I ever actually learn to like Deadlock, I will have a reverse character development.
More toxic?
Is that even possible?
I mean, I got to this point without ever learning a MOBA game.
So like, it would be crazy if that's a possibility.
Like I got to that point of toxicity while ever learning MOBAs.
So I could actually go further.
All right.
Anyway, let me teach.
Let me not teach you guys.
I barely can teach myself.
Let me.
Okay.
So this is what I learned.
So anyway.
Oh yeah.
By the way.
So like I learned you can like do builds and stuff.
So this is my, the one, the build.
So you can browse builds here.
And I like favorited this.
And then this teaches you what to upgrade, which I'm going to fucking forget anyway.
I know I'm going to forget this.
So this is the build I'm on.
It's called Punchy McFace Puncher.
Because I was like, it was the most popular.
So I was like, let's do that.
Punchy McFace Puncher.
So this is what, this is what Shurford taught me.
I charge in, I punch, and I hit.
That's it.
So I'm doing, that's all I have to do.
Or.
Or I do this.
I smash.
Doki smash.
And then, wait.
Oh, that's my teammate.
Whoops.
Oh no.
So I need to like change the settings.
Definitely.
Okay.
Video.
We'll do fastest.
We don't need to look pretty here.
Okay.
There you go.
This game looks like shit now.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
This game looks like.
Okay.
Anyway.
How do I.
Wait.
How do I make it to the sandbox?
Um.
Wait.
How do I change the sandbox?
Oh my god.
Turn off upscaling.
Oh, maybe I do that.
Okay.
Let me try.
Uh.
Okay.
We'll do this.
And then.
What do I do?
Here.
Do I.
Okay.
What.
Guys.
How do I fix.
Hold tap.
Okay.
What do I.
What do I turn off to make myself better?
Render quality at a hundred percent.
All.
Okay.
Remove.
There's no motion there.
Oh my god.
There is.
I'm.
Automatically.
Nevermind.
I'm off to a good start.
By the way.
It's my birthday.
Hope you have fun with dialogue.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Mega.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Okay.
Guys.
What do I have to do?
Dashboard.
Oh wait.
Why am I at 120 frames?
The fuck?
180.
Okay.
Guys.
What do I do?
To.
Cause like.
Obviously.
I'm lagging a little bit.
Guys.
Other than uninstall.
We'll do that later.
Uh.
What.
What should.
Uh.
FPS to lower?
Crank error.
Okay.
Wait.
Really?
Okay.
Oh.
Is this for like.
Dashboard.
Uh.
Wait.
I thought.
But like.
Post process bloom?
It's only.
Oh.
It's only the dashboard?
Wait.
How about like regular then?
I don't even.
What was the default?
I don't remember.
110 is fine.
That's fine.
Oh.
Here you go.
In game.
Oh.
There it is.
Okay.
200.
I'll do 200.
I don't need.
I have a 208.
Nah.
Let's do 240 actually.
Plus.
And quality.
FS.
R2.
Quality.
Uh.
Or stretch.
Plus 100.
Render.
This?
Okay.
Render quality.
The 100%.
What else?
Guys.
The frames.
Frames are very important.
It's very important.
In the shooter game.
You.
Use FS2?
This one?
Moderate.
To.
Consistent.
Okay.
I'll put it here.
Uh.
And then what?
What do I do after that?
Guys.
Uh.
I'm going to put the frame lower.
Quality.
Okay.
All right.
Is there anything else?
Turn off distance.
Field.
Field shadows.
Do we need.
Do we need shadows?
No.
We don't need shadows.
Okay.
That should be good.
Right?
Apply.
Okay.
We should be okay.
We should be okay now.
Okay.
So.
Uh.
No death.
No cooldown.
Okay.
So this is what I was taught.
I was really taught to do this.
And then do that.
And then pew.
And then do this.
And then that.
And then pew.
So apparently.
You can parry.
So you go here.
And like.
Learn how to parry.
Okay.
Sorry.
And then go here.
And then learn how to parry.
Please.
Please sir.
There we go.
And then I was also taught this.
And I had to do that.
And then pew.
And then boom.
And then charge.
And then smash.
So that's like literally everything I was taught.
That was.
And then.
That's all I know.
That's literally all I know.
That's.
Alright.
So.
Okay.
Now I'm gonna get absolutely destroyed.
Yeah.
It's F.
F is.
I don't know if.
I think.
I don't know if F is.
If this is universal one.
I'll never use the parry.
But like.
I hope the other players don't use the parry too.
That's what I'm hoping for.
As long as the other players don't use it.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
Please.
So this is where you test the parry.
Woo.
Look at that.
Yeah.
Alright.
We should be fine.
We're going back.
We're gonna go straight in.
Alright.
Guys.
We'll see how this goes.
Play deadlock.
I swear to god.
This is literally the only character I know how to play right now.
And then.
We'll try these guys.
These three.
I sort of vaguely know.
I sort of vaguely know how to play these two.
Because like.
Um.
I read a little bit.
So we'll see.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm so tired.
I'm so nervous.
Learning new games is always so stressful.
I swear to god.
If I'm not able.
Okay.
Thank god.
I swear to god.
If I'm not able.
I'm gonna.
I swear to god.
You don't want.
Like it.
When I'm mad.
Okay.
Here we go.
It's time to learn.
It's time to fucking learn.
Um.
I have no.
You guys are gonna be yelling at me.
A lot.
You're.
You're gonna be yelling at me.
A lot.
Lot.
Because I don't know what's going on.
Look.
I do four damage.
Also it's like fucking Kovacs too.
Like the deny and stuff.
Like the.
You have to deny people.
Oh.
I swear to god.
If you steal my fucking Kovacs.
I'm already like.
Having a rough time.
What is he doing here?
Get out.
Stop.
So this is the MOBA part of the game.
Where you have to just.
Shoot them.
Until you can't shoot no more.
Are you serious?
Who shot me?
Don't make me fucking come over here.
Don't make me come over here.
You.
No.
I can't.
I can come over here.
I will charge.
I was taught how to melee.
Oh yeah.
If I do this.
Like it instead.
Takes the.
The Kovac shit.
Away.
Can you show us?
Show you guys what?
Am I laning by myself?
Are you?
What?
Wait.
What do you mean?
I'm laning by myself.
Where's my buddy?
I've never had to do solo lanes.
Please.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I.
Please don't do this to me.
Please.
I'm in a solo lane.
This is bad.
I'm already.
Like.
It's already rough for me.
Please.
No!
Okay, I'll upgrade now.
Alright.
Here we go.
I just follow the guide.
That's how I do things.
Guys, I told you.
You're gonna be yelling at me a lot, guys.
I know.
Wait.
Don't make me come over here.
I will.
Don't fucking make me walk over there.
Because I will.
I have my charge.
You think I won't?
You might have range.
But the moment you get over here, I swear to God, I will fucking charge you.
Please.
No, I couldn't deny him.
But I wanna upgrade this.
Fine.
Wait.
Get over here!
You know you want to.
You know you wanna get over here.
I will fucking charge soon.
The moment I can have the ability to charge at you, I will fucking do it.
She's cucked.
Oh my God.
Get out.
Get out of here.
You fucking miss.
You're so bad.
I don't know what I'm doing, but at least I'm not missing.
Like...
At least I'm not missing, guys.
Oh, I don't even need a... I don't even need an aim down sight.
Get over here.
I'm fucking heading over.
I'm gonna head over.
I'm gonna fucking... Oh, you're gonna run away, you fucking pussy.
You know.
You know what I wanna do.
You fucking know.
You fucking know what I wanna do.
Alright.
That's fine.
You're gonna deny me my stuff?
You're such a... You're such a bitch!
I'm fucking coming over.
I don't fucking care.
Fuck off, actually.
How you're gonna leave?
I can't believe that's fucking right.
He fucking ran, this little fucker.
I can't believe he actually ran.
Oh, I'm going to go crazy.
I'm actually going to fucking go crazy.
Holy shit.
I'm going to go crazy here.
This 1v1.
But I'm so low, I can't.
Push him.
Oh my god.
I'm just way too low.
Where is he?
Alright.
I'm already losing.
No, you don't understand.
When nothing happens, I go crazy.
Like, you don't...
I go crazy when nothing is happening in here.
It makes me go insane.
Fucker.
This has to be, like, the most unlucky matchup for me.
Where is he?
Oh my god.
Please.
It's just a really...
He's literally won.
Fucking heal me, creep.
Like, when nothing happens.
Oh my god.
When nothing...
I swear to god.
If he fucking takes this too.
I go insane.
It's more insane than usual.
Is he going to heal?
Okay.
Where is he?
Am I by myself?
Where the...
Oh my god.
He went all the way back.
Bitch.
Fucking bitch.
That's fine.
I don't know what my team is doing, but that's fine.
My team might be, like, getting fucked over.
But that's okay.
That's okay.
Bro.
You went back to spawn?
You fucking loser.
I'll go back to spawn.
Fuck off.
I'll go back to spawn and full heal.
I might as well.
Okay, I'm gonna full heal.
Guys, I...
I'll try not to go too crazy.
Okay, I hear you.
If he's gonna full heal, I'll full heal.
How long is the lane experience?
The moment it hits the 15 minute mark, I actually will go insane.
I go insane because nothing has happened.
It has happened.
I need you guys to know it has absolutely happened.
I have absolutely...
It has absolutely...
Ow.
You bitch.
You fucker.
You're an actual fucker.
I hate this guy.
I hate him.
I hate him so much.
I'm getting hard... I don't wanna be in this lane!
All he does is jump!
Everything I learned is useless!
Everything I learned...
It didn't matter!
It didn't fucking matter!
I learned this character just to get fucking hard counted by this grandpa!
Oh my god, you're such a whore.
You're actually such a whore.
I hope this keynotch...
I hope your character gets nerfed to the fucking ground.
And you have nothing else in your life.
Imagine like clearly...
Clearly you played this character so much!
But you're in my elo!
Like how fucking bad are you to be in my elo?
After all of that!
Like...
I barely know what I'm doing and yet you're here.
You're here in this elo.
Don't bully it.
It's not even grandma!
It's a grandpa!
Okay, maybe...
Oh, there's a trap.
I'm fucking farming.
Bro, fuck this.
Bro, okay.
I swear to god, if you fucking...
Yeah, you see that?
I'm fucking... I'm gonna punch your ass.
I'm gonna go fucking farm this.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna steal your creep.
I'm gonna steal this.
Oh yeah, you're scared?
You're so scared.
Yeah, I see you.
That's okay.
I see you.
You're so fucking scared.
That's right.
Get over here!
Fucking get over here!
Yeah, you can't do jack shit!
I'm fucking taking this!
You can't aim for this too!
That's right!
You're so bad.
You're so fucking...
Oh yeah!
That's fucking...
Wait, is that your friend?
What the fu...
Okay.
I...
Now you have friends?
Like...
What?
Okay.
Bro...
Actually, fuck you.
Where are my friends?
Like, where...
Okay.
Bro.
Nothing's happening.
It's...
We're at the 15-minute mark soon.
We're almost there.
Okay!
There should be...
There should be another person in my lane too.
Where are my friends?
I thought I had friends too!
Wait...
Oh my God.
And they're both flying characters.
That's the worst.
That's the worst part.
Dude.
I fucking hate all of you.
Like...
They're all flying characters too!
This sucks!
Everything I learned, it didn't mean anything.
Oh my God.
I'm just a lonely bird, trying to make it in this fucked up world.
Alright, goodbye.
I was left alone.
Dad!
Oh my gosh.
Alright, I'm leaving this lane.
You guys, good luck everybody.
Good luck everybody, I'm fucking leaving this lane.
I don't want to be in that lane no more.
I don't want to be in this lane no more.
I can't get anything done.
I don't believe it.
What do you want me to do?
What do they want me to do?
I'm just a poor fucking...
I can't get that urn, man.
There's... okay.
I'm gonna...
Alright.
Oh my god, I swear to fucking god.
You're such a bitch.
Where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
Where did the grandma go?
Oh, thank god!
Other people helped me.
Oh my god, I actually have friends.
That's fucking crazy.
I actually have friends.
I actually have friends now.
I don't know how that... this is the first time.
I don't wanna...
Oh, what?
Oh, fuck it.
That's what the bird is.
Okay, at least now I know what the bird is.
Guys, I know it's like really rough right now watching me play.
Like, I absolutely know.
Don't worry.
I know.
I'm trying my best.
I'm just getting incredibly countered by people that can jump.
Okay, jump has a long cooldown.
Okay, that's good.
Like, he's literally waiting for my jump too.
Oh my god, I have a friend.
Oh, thank you.
That's all I wanted, a friend.
Wait, did he die?
Oh, shit.
Oh, goodbye.
That's like, wait a minute.
You're not... you weren't there before.
Three?
Okay.
That's fine.
Back to just following like...
Just following this step-by-step guide.
Okay.
What do I...
What do I do after this?
Okay.
One.
Two.
Oh.
Okay.
Why can't we be friends?
Should have trusted your pink one as a boss.
Like, gee boy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How would...
How did I...
How could I have known that I was going to get hard countered by literally...
The...
The two...
The two characters that can do such big jumps.
I fucking...
That's right.
I still...
That...
I know that's overkill, but I needed this.
Like, I...
I fucking needed that.
You don't understand.
I was so desperate.
I...
I had so much hate that I needed that.
I swear to God...
It was a mental win.
Hehehe.
Mentally, that was a win for me.
You don't understand.
Why do I shoot for this guy?
This has been the furthest I've ever been to this one guy.
What do I...
Oh okay...
I just shoot him.
Okay.
Push.
Come on!
Yeeeaaah!
We did it, team!
I don't...
I'm fucking...
I'm just going to upgrade all of this.
Okay.
We did it!
This is what it feels like!
This is what it feels like to have friends!
Oh my god!
Don't worry, I got you, bro!
I- Sorry, I fucking left already.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Please.
I can't- I can't push in, I'm sorry.
Look at them, they're so far away!
I don't- Am I winning or am I- That is a very good question, by the way.
Oh, he left!
That's fine.
That's absolutely fine.
That- Oh, wait.
We should all leave, actually.
No, I should leave too.
No, they're heading over.
They're heading over.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Okay, goodbye.
No, no, you're right.
You're right.
I'll- No, you're right.
You guys can have that.
You're- You guys- You guys can have that.
I don't need it.
I'll take this, though.
I don't even know what- Oh, I'll take this too.
Just take that.
Get over here.
Boom.
Punch.
Okay, now I'm punching this.
I want money.
I'm desperate.
Give me my money.
Nice.
Yay!
Oh, shit, I gotta help!
Sorry, I was too busy farming.
I felt like the main character for a sec.
Sorry, I should help out now.
He is jump!
You know what that means!
That's fu- Oh, you bitch!
Oh, you use jump too.
That's fucking right!
Yeah!
That's fucking right, you whore!
Oh my god, it's the best feeling in the world.
This is really the...
Wait, do you need help?
Okay, I was like, I thought he was okay.
Someone get ass!
Oh my god, he used jump, guys!
He actually used jump, guys!
Holy shit!
This is it!
This is my character arc right here!
Wait, did I not kill him?
Baby, get down, baby!
Get down!
I need your money!
I'm so behind anyway!
Oh shit!
Oh, this is what it feels like!
Where's the shop?
I don't know where I have...
Oh no, the shop's closed!
Okay.
Wait, did somebody die?
Who died?
Where the fuck is the shop?
Where is the shop?
Why'd they go back to base?
Okay, well...
Sorry.
I'm new around here.
To the base I go.
You know what?
Fuck it.
This is a pub anyway.
Your heavy melee gives you 100% bonus.
You don't need to suffer reloading.
Oh yeah, I keep forgetting.
Alright.
Now off I go.
Do I know what I bought?
That's a good question.
Oh, you don't jump!
I'm heading over to you.
I'm heading over!
I know you don't jump!
Oh!
You think I'm...
Oh, you think I'm scared of you?
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
Oh!
Wait, where did you go?
Oh, you think you can run?
Oh shit, you can.
You can't jump!
That's a key, right?
I fucking know that you can't jump too!
Oh, hey.
You're coming over.
Oh shit.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh, my god, no!
What the fuck is that damage!?
Holy shit!
I even charged her!
Oh, my God!
Holy shit!
That didn't matter!
Her damage was insane!
She has 28k souls?
Okay.
Oh, destroy item.
Oh, I have this.
Holy shit, who the fuck fit?
Oh my god, now she has 29k!
I was not paying attention to where the fuck was that.
I was just like, holy shit.
Wait, this guy.
How can you be bad at Infernus?
Isn't he like one of the most OP characters?
How?
Okay.
Anyway, don't be mad.
It's Aves.
She's the only problem.
This guy.
Okay, things make more sense now.
Alright.
Maybe I can... guys, maybe I can catch up.
Guys.
Guys, maybe I can catch up.
Guys, if I farm these guys, maybe I can catch up.
Maybe.
Maybe I can catch up with the babies.
Guys, maybe.
Guys, it could be possible.
It could be possible.
No.
Guys, it could be possible.
You don't know that.
Like, right here.
It could be possible, guys.
Oh my god, again?
Whoa.
He doesn't know.
Oh shit, I should leave.
My teammate left, so I was like, okay, hey guys, I'm back.
I was like, there's four people.
I leave now.
I leave.
The hit and run.
The hit and run special.
As long as the haze is not near me.
I have 40k.
I don't know how to farm.
I don't know how to farm properly.
That is...
Okay.
Guys, I don't know.
Is it obvious that I don't know what I'm doing?
I don't think so, right?
I don't...
Like, even though I'm like, you know, very behind.
Oh shit!
Don't worry, I'm coming over!
Oh shit, nevermind!
Whoo!
I... I'm here now.
I'm here to assist.
Boom, there we go.
She's so low.
I helped.
I helped!
Yay!
I'm helping.
I'm doing it.
Oh wait, I cancelled her ult!
Yeah, I knew what I was doing.
I... I definitely knew what I was doing.
Guys.
I definitely was intentional.
So intentional.
Shit, I'm just a gamer.
I'm just a fucking gamer.
What can I say?
What can I fucking say?
What do I do now?
Oh my god, she used jump!
I know you used jump!
Fucking do it!
Wait, where did you go?
Where did she go?
Oh, that's fucking right!
Get punched!
Okay, I'm fucking leaving.
No!
It's okay.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
We're so healthy, guys.
We're okay.
Okay, all our teammates dying.
But that's okay.
I'm fucking getting rid of these guys though.
Oh god.
Oh, no!
Bebop!
No!
I'm sorry!
Bebop!
It's okay.
I lived though.
I will avenge you, Bebop!
I will...
I will avenge you.
I am poor?
Oh wait, I'm not at the shop.
It's like, what?
Of everything I find?
Okay, there you go.
I'm not even at the shop.
And I thought I was poor.
I was confused.
I was so confused.
But I have to go in order!
Oh, you're right.
I'll upgrade my ult.
Okay.
Go up.
There we go.
Oh, maybe I'll grab... get stuff.
Oh, yeah.
I knew it.
That's fucking right!
Yeah!
Let's go, buddy!
Let's go!
That's right.
Teamwork!
Guys, I still...
I don't know if you guys know this, but I still...
I still don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
Oh, shit!
Don't make me use this.
That's fine.
I helped out.
Don't worry.
I got you, bro.
I got you.
Don't worry.
Oh, that's your ult, right?
Yeah, that's your ult.
I'm fucking...
Oh, my God!
What the fu...
Guys!
What the fuck happened there?
Holy sh...
I'm fucking... I'm...
See ya.
See...
Run!
I couldn't cancel!
She was... You saw her?
You saw what the fuck she just did?
I was like, bye!
Oh, yeah.
I heard the duration extender is really good.
Maybe I can grab some extra.
Here.
I need this so bad.
Oh, hey, maybe?
No.
Alright.
Yeah, I saw that.
That was scary as fuck.
Oh, did they kill her?
No, they killed us.
Okay, I should help out.
I'm a little lost.
Bebop!
Bebop, come back!
You can't run forever, bitch!
That's fucking right!
You can't fucking run forever!
You thought you could get away?
I will fucking punch your ass!
I will learn to fear seven.
Where are they?
Where is she?
Oh, you're over here.
You're over here.
I see your...
I see your ass right now.
Who is he trying to fight?
Oh, her!
Okay.
That's...
Oh shit!
Okay.
Oh my god!
Okay, she is fucking...
I'm outta here.
You win this.
Goodbye.
I'm fucking outta here.
They're afraid.
Yeah, I can tell.
I can tell they're fucking afraid.
Holy shit.
They like ran away so fast.
I was like...
I saw them running and I was like...
Oh, I know why.
Now I know why they were running.
Let's see.
Oh, it's grandma.
Or grandpa.
What the fuck?
You fucker.
You're an actual fucker.
I see you.
I fucking see...
Where did he go?
That's fucking right.
I'm fucking heading over here.
You think I won't?
I see you.
Okay, I lost him.
I don't see him anymore.
Oh my god!
I wanna get this guy so badly!
Rage quit on me.
They lost to his!
Let's fucking go!
I am no longer afraid.
I...
They lost to his.
No longer shall I fear you.
That's fucking right.
You think I fear you now?
No longer shall I be afraid.
That's right.
I'm heading over.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking...
Oh yeah, you know I'm heading over.
You know I'm heading over!
I'm fucking right here at your door!
Knock knock, baby!
Knock knock!
Oh!
Okay, that was...
That's awkward.
Guys?
Where's my team?
Okay, guys, I'm back.
Guys, I'm back to the fight.
I was just waiting for you guys.
I distracted.
You're welcome.
I was the opener.
Guys, I was literally the opener.
I opened it.
I initiated, guys.
I initiated.
Yay!
Look at that.
I'm so fucking good.
She did that.
Just a distraction.
Alright.
Yeah, that was...
Yeah, that was bottom fragger.
That seems right.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
49,000?
Yeah.
I did my best.
I did it.
Yeah, I don't have 9 deaths at least.
But not...
Yeah, bottom damage, but not bottom frag.
That's true.
Come on and slam and welcome to the jam.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, positive KDA.
Positive KDA.
I'm learning.
At least I'm learning.
Alright.
First win of the day.
Let's go.
Yay!
Positive KDA.
Anyway, so that's Abram.
Apparently the...
One of the easiest characters to play.
Because, um...
You know, all he does is punch.
Alright.
I wanna actually try the sniper lady.
The sniper lady seems really fun.
But like, I need to figure out what her build is.
Um...
I was told that she has like this really...
She has either...
You either do speed build or...
Um...
A speed build or a spirit build.
Whatever the fuck that means.
Whatever.
It's either speed or power.
But I don't know which one.
Sniper TP has sexy feet build.
Okay.
Oh, is that the build?
Is that what it... Is that the feet?
Okay, like the fast build is so funny.
Not gonna lie.
Which one is it?
Is it this one?
Is it...
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I didn't see the full name.
Is it this one?
Sorry.
Is it?
Okay, so apparently this makes you go incredibly fast.
Early farm lane until max ult and then put...
I don't know.
Which one is...
Okay, improved build versus a lot works like...
Which one is the fast build?
Which one is it?
I want the fast one.
Because I don't know which one is the super fast incredible feet DPS.
Okay.
Incredible feet D... Oh my god.
This is so dumb.
Incredible...
It's not it!
That's not it!
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
There you go.
Okay.
What is it called?
Incredible...
Is it actually?
Okay.
Guys, which one is it?
Uh...
I wanna be super fast!
That's all I wanna be!
Okay.
Sexy movement.
Is it this one?
The boring...
The boring part.
Damn.
Okay.
Flex.
Wait.
But I need like...
Um... Why is it...
Because it's all... You're super fast!
That's why!
That's literally it!
You're just so fucking fast!
I wonder if this one is...
I don't know which one it is!
Which one is it?
There's so many feet builds!
Which one is the right one?
Which one is the right build?
There's so many!
Oh!
It's been nerfed!
Alright.
Nevermind.
I guess I'll use this.
Apparently they nerfed it.
They...
I guess we'll just... We'll just do this.
We'll just do whatever is the first one.
Um...
Just go with the most popular one.
Enduring speed?
Why does it say enduring speed?
Lucky shot.
Uh...
First fire.
Where's enduring speed?
There's have a lot.
Oh!
There it is!
Enduring speed.
Okay.
We'll just do this.
The most boring name one.
Um...
The spirit one I heard was really good too.
Cause I was like... Okay.
So basically...
Yes.
Pew pew pew pew pew pew.
See I told you guys.
I told you the noobs don't know how to parry.
Cause I don't even parry.
They don't know how to parry.
I told you guys.
But no.
No.
The 10 to 15 minutes of the lane part.
Oh my god.
I fucking wanna die.
Like doing the lane part.
I...
That part like actually just pisses me off so much.
I'm just like... Please.
Get me out of the lane.
Like...
Please.
I hate...
I hate it here so much.
Okay.
We gotta get the tether...
Let's say any movement is restricted to the... Oh!
This is like the Ash Q.
Ash Q and then Crow and then Flight.
And then Fly in the air and then Sniper.
Okay.
I was going insane into...
No you don't.
I was gonna go fucking crazy.
Also, is Sound Guy here?
How's the sound been?
I hope the sound hasn't been too loud.
Chat.
I hope it hasn't been too loud, guys.
Make high priority.
Oh!
Okay.
You said it was good?
That's good.
As long as you guys thought it was... I didn't see I was too busy going crazy in the lane.
But like...
negative connotation.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh!
Violet's first prio?
Okay.
Here we go.
Wait.
Is her name... I wish...
I just... The only thing I don't like about the character design is that...
I know it's supposed to fit the environment but the color is so dull.
I'm not a fan of that.
Oh!
Thank god.
Okay.
I'm not... I'm not Abrum.
So I'm fine with laning against you.
I'm fine...
I'm fine with laning against you.
I'm not...
I'm not Abrum anymore.
So it's okay.
I just don't like how dull the colors are.
It just doesn't...
I don't know.
I need sparkly colors.
I need bright colors.
Uh...
No, I meant the characters.
I feel like the characters are like...
Colors seem very...
dull in general.
There's no brightly colored characters at all.
But I guess because you want them to be able to be able to hide and stuff.
You don't want to be able to be seen.
Uh...
Yeah, it's so muted.
Yeah.
It's so muted.
In general.
Uh... John, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations on your first win.
Welcome to the Deadlock experience.
Not gonna lie, that game we had today had to be the most fun I've had playing Deadlock.
Like...
Despite how fucking tilting playing against this fucker was as Abrum, um... the moment, like...
She didn't jump.
It was so easy.
It was...
The moment he couldn't...
The moment I broke his fucking shins.
Like... The moment I broke this grandpa's ankles, it was over for him.
It was so fucking over.
Grandpa was fucking dead.
Imma break your fucking ankles.
Alright.
Anyway.
I swear to god.
I can't believe my lane had all the characters that fucking countered me.
That was so tilting.
I was like, are you serious?
You can fucking jump?
Like, fuck off!
Go to a different lane!
Go...
Yay!
No, people were pausing the game, I think.
Oh, I don't have shoes.
No wonder.
Oh no, she's the jury.
She's the jury.
She's the jury of deadlock.
The one ult where they both flew away.
Oh god.
That's...
That hurt my soul.
Alright, this is Kovacs simulator now.
Guys, are you guys ready for Kovacs simulator?
I'm so ready.
I'm so ready to Kovacs.
How much ammo do I have?
Okay, I should reload before I shoot this one guy.
Do I need to?
Oh, I don't even need to aim down sight.
What the fuck?
Aiming down sight is for fucking pussies.
I can...
Okay, except for Kovac moment.
Early...
Get over here.
Get your ass over here, grandpa.
Grandpa.
That's fucking right.
Oh, our guy already killed somebody?
Nice.
I fucking knew it.
Alright, nice.
It's fine.
Am I solo laning again?
Oh, I am.
Oh, god damn it.
I am.
I am solo laning.
It's fine.
I don't need help.
If I didn't need help as Abram, I don't need help now.
I don't need help now, guys.
I'm perfectly fine solo laning.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay, guys.
Oh, you missed, you fucker.
That's fucking rude.
You think you can hide from me?
Guys, sorry.
I have to reload.
You can because I have to reload.
You think because you're in the air I'm scared?
Bro, this is like Duck Hunt.
Oh, you can't shoot when I saw it.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
You can't aim for shit, grandpa.
That's fucking right.
You're fucking so bad.
Oh, my god.
You're so bad.
You're so...
Congratulations on hitting your first shot, bro.
Actually, congratulations.
Holy shit.
Learn how to shoot better before you fucking contest me.
Oh, you're scared, aren't you?
I'm gonna go bye.
You might as well.
Bro, this guy can't aim.
He literally can't aim.
It's so sad.
Alright, I'm coming over, grandpa.
I'm coming over, grandpa.
I'm heading back, grandpa.
That's right.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you think I'm scared?
Wait, I am.
Wait, what the fuck?
He doesn't do single shot anymore.
What did he buy?
What did you buy?
How does he do that?
What did he buy?
He does spread shot.
What a cheater.
Actually cheating because he can't aim.
So now he has to do a spread shot to actually do things.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, now he has to fucking cheat.
Oh my god.
Hacks.
Just cause you have spread shot doesn't mean you're good.
Alright.
I wanna use this right now.
Just cause I want to.
I have plenty of time.
I wanna use my abilities but I don't think I'm gonna hit that though.
That's why I haven't used it.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, you're gonna run?
You're gonna run now?
Fucking bitch.
That's looking right.
Oh, you're gonna jump you fucker.
You fucker.
I can't afford it yet.
Okay.
I can't afford this.
I don't know what to get first.
I'm going crazy again.
I'm actually gonna go crazy here again.
I'm gonna fucking...
We're back here again.
We're actually back here.
Oh my god.
I think I dodged that?
No, I didn't.
That's right.
You thought you could trap me?
I see you.
I fucking see you.
I like how it's always like crew is kinda hard to hit and then I hit it.
Oh, he's so low.
He's so low.
Swear to god.
Please.
I need my ult.
I need my fucking ult at this point.
That's right.
Don't get near me.
Don't you get near me, bitch.
You're literally out aiming.
The only way he fucking shoots hits me is if...
Literally the only way he hits me is if he does that spread shot.
Oh no.
This is bad.
This is actually bad.
Holy shit.
No.
No!
That spread shot!
He got the spread shot!
Don't worry.
You're gonna lose out because...
How did he... Oh my... I've not been farming.
I just realized, guys.
Alright.
It's time to farm.
I don't know the farming shit.
The farming shit is what throws me off every time.
He out farmed me.
I'm so sad.
Alright, guys.
It's time for farm.
I need this.
I need a farm.
I'm so fucking poor.
Give me... You're too weak?
That's loser talk.
Clearly, I wasn't too weak.
That's loser talk because I was able to farm it in the end.
I got teethered him.
Nice.
I teethered him.
Bye.
I don't like holding it because I feel like I'm more accurate tapping it.
This fucky.
Oh my god.
He fucking distracted me.
All I did was shot him.
He knew.
He knew I was too...
He knew all I wanted to do was shoot him.
He was so smart.
I wasn't farming because all I wanted to do was shoot this guy.
I hate him.
No, I'm doing it again.
I just want to shoot him.
I just... I can fly too, bitch.
I can also fly.
That's fucking right.
I...
I can also fly.
Oh, get teethered.
I need to farm so badly.
I've not been doing it.
Okay.
I don't even have ult.
Wait.
What?
Fuck you.
I heard it.
I was like, wait.
What was that?
I, like, turned around.
I was like...
Alright, guys.
I'm leaving my lane.
It's not worth it.
I'm gonna farm.
I'm gonna go farm some stuff.
Oh, no.
Grandma's coming over.
She has...
I don't even have my ult.
Grandma.
Please.
I'm leaving.
My teammate can handle this.
I need to farm.
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'll be able to farm.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
That's fine.
And then...
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
I'll have my stuff now.
It's over.
I have my ult.
After 20 years, I have my ult.
It's over for her.
It's so over.
Guys, I missed.
It'll be over soon.
If I don't miss.
There we go.
Holy shit!
Okay, she's...
She's too much.
She's too strong.
Okay.
Maybe I should never swap off of Abra.
Alright, time to farm.
Yay!
Toki, you need to help your team.
Guys, I...
I will...
I'm helping by farming.
Alright.
Why are you so...
Why are you so poor?
Guys, please.
Please don't...
All I did was shot the grandma.
I didn't farm anything.
I just wanted to shoot, guys.
I...
I didn't...
I didn't farm any souls because all I wanted to do was shoot the grandma.
I got a friend!
Sorry.
I know I should have farmed.
And then all she was doing...
I don't have the MOBA brain!
I just want to pew-pew!
Really, that's all I want to do.
I just wanted to pew-pew and...
And it...
It fucked me over.
It literally fucked me over because of it.
Oh, I teetered him though.
Oh my god.
He has, like, almost doubled my souls.
I'm so fucked.
At least I'm farming now!
Guys, look!
I'm learning!
I'm farming again!
I need to deny that.
Oh my god.
Guys, look!
Look, I'm doing it!
Oh my god.
What?
He's so strong!
Holy fuck!
He's so...
He's so... Guys, we're so fucked.
He's too...
He's too buff for my fucking character.
I like how...
He's like, I can't win the farm.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
My...
I don't have the boba brain.
I'm sorry.
I don't have...
When I see people, I just want to shoot them, not the fucking creep.
It's just... I just...
I'm like, why do I shoot the weak minions when I can shoot... Guys!
Why is nobody helping me fight the grandpa?
Oh my god.
He's just there!
He's literally solo fucking...
He's so...
I can't... I can't do anything about it because he's so much stronger than me.
That's actually so fucked.
Like...
I can't win this 1v1.
I'm not big fist man.
I'm trying my best.
I am.
I truly am.
I'll just farm these mini guys.
I need this so bad.
I... Guys, please!
I need these more than you!
Guys, please!
I'm...
Look at me!
Don't take them away!
I need this more!
Please!
Nice.
We're fine.
Okay, this is fine.
This is okay.
Alright, now...
Okay, after this, maybe we're just meant to be Abram.
Or we can try Haze!
Haze seems like a fun DPS character.
Apparently, Haze is really good for late game or some shit.
Okay.
See?
Look!
Look, I'm doing it.
I'm fucking doing it.
Don't worry!
She's coming!
He's coming!
200 million damage!
Team, please!
He has so much HP!
He has so much damage!
Team!
I need... I can't solo push him!
I literally can't 1v1 him!
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
That's fine.
I'll farm here.
I'll take here as my farm.
Guys, I already miss Abram.
I miss playing Abram so much.
Nice!
I miss Abram.
Abram was fun.
Abram was so fun.
I already miss Abram.
Let's see.
Oh, where do I put Quicksilver bullets?
I don't know where, so I didn't bother.
Oh my god, they're over there!
Okay.
Wait, I got help.
Okay, nice.
Guys, see?
I'm doing it.
No stink, just punch.
That's true.
Wait, did he got killed by Grandpa?
Okay.
Oh, we unlocked flex slot!
We did it, team!
We fucking did it, team!
Together!
Guys, we fucking did it!
Okay.
Nice.
We got that.
Yippee!
Oh, he took out Grandpa!
Yay!
Oh my god.
That's great.
Now I can be safe.
I'm not like...
I'm not like the weakest in terms of... Oh, there's two people that DC'd!
Yay!
Thank god.
I don't get punished for...
I don't get punished for not fucking doing anything.
I love it when you don't get punished.
Yippee!
Never punished!
Free win!
I just want the Grandpa to DC so he could leave me alone.
Honestly, I want the Grandpa to fucking leave.
Yay!
Where's my team?
Like, how did I get here?
I'm gonna fucking walk to my teammates.
Oh hey, free stuff.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, team!
I haven't been helpful whatsoever, but don't worry.
This is where it stops.
This is where it starts, being helpful.
This is it.
Right here!
Look at that!
I'm so helpful.
Oh god.
Wait.
Oh no.
I think the Gra- I heard the Grandpa.
Fear.
Actual fear.
I heard the Grandpa and I felt real fear.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Act- Fear!
Oh my god.
Actual fear.
Wait.
Did my game crash?
What?
What happened?
Where am I?
What?
Is this replay?
Oh, that was replay.
I was like- Oh, I pressed R accidentally.
I accidentally played R.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Quicksilver.
Oh!
Quicksilver on 4.
Okay.
Enduring speed.
Guys, I don't like her.
I think I am an Arma player.
I'm definitely an Arma player.
Chat.
I'm 100%- Wait.
What?
Did the fucking Grandpa solo got all of this himself?
Jesus Christ.
Or maybe I try Haze.
Maybe I'm more of a Haze player.
Maybe.
From- From fucking- From the fucking Fister to Sniper, we know where my place is.
I was a better Fister than a than a Sniper.
That's for sure.
There we go.
I helped.
No, what?
You know what I said.
It's true.
You know I- You know I was doing great.
I was doing great with it.
Oh, wait.
I- I misclicked that.
I wish I was fast.
I wish I- No, Bebop is like- He's like Roadhog.
And I fucking- I'm so bad at Roadhog though.
That's the thing.
I'm so bad at Roadhog.
So like, I don't think- I don't think it's possible for me to- I'm scared.
I'm scared.
I know like Haze has like a lot of DPS though.
I know that.
Oh.
Oh no, I'm scared.
Guys, I don't want to get- That's fine.
I was gonna say, I don't want the grandpa to hit me.
Oh fuck, okay.
Yay!
It's fine.
Team is fine.
Team is so fine.
Oh, sorry.
I have grandpa PTSD right now.
I actually- I actually have grandpa PTSD every time.
I'm like looking behind me and being like, is he there?
Is he- Is he there?
Like- I know what I'm scared of.
I'm so scared of him.
I'm actually so scared of him.
Oh, so that's what it does!
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Can I just shoot this guy?
No, it's too far.
Okay.
What do I do?
Do I just do this?
What do I do when I'm in the air?
I'm just like, What do I do when I'm in the air?
I just do that?
I guess I do.
Do I enjoy- It depends on what I'm- It depends on who- My lane.
I feel like.
Right now, this is my first time playing the sniper lady.
And I- I also don't know what I'm doing.
So like, there's also that.
Like-
I don't know what- Too far?
When am I not- When am I close enough?
Like here?
Okay, here.
Okay.
Alright, we figured it out.
I was like, too far?
I'm literally right next to him!
How am I too far?
Wait, my base?
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Oops.
Okay.
That's fine.
My teammates got this, right?
Who's attacking my shrine?
It's Grandpa!
Who else?
It's always Grandpa!
Grandpa!
It's- It's always him!
He's always attacking my shrine!
He's always there!
It's always him.
Every time.
Wait, I need to be in the pit.
This is stupid.
Okay.
I actually have to be in this pit to do this.
What if I just do that?
Yay!
I did it.
I don't know what I was doing, but I did it.
I wanna try Haze.
I think Haze might be more fun because it's more DPS intensive.
Oh, hey!
23,000.
Holy f- How did she do- How did you do worse than me?
Oh!
Sorry.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh!
At least it's fine.
Oh my god!
How?
1,900!
Thank god!
Thank god you carried me.
Thank god she carried me.
Okay.
So now I'm gonna try Haze.
Honestly, it's still Abrams.
Abrams is my favorite still.
Uh, I don't know about Haze though.
Apparently she has a steep dart like Ana.
Like this.
It makes her- makes them go...
eepy?
It makes them go eepy?
And then...
there's the smoke bomb.
And... what's this?
Oh yeah, this is the Reaper ult!
This is it!
Okay, this is...
This is the...
This is the Reaper ult.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
Alright, build time.
We gotta figure out the build.
Alright, uh...
I guess...
Oh, it's all-time favorite!
Wait, what's better?
More improvements.
The change has felt great and is more in line with Haze.
From the original comes a more diverse arrangement of the bulletproof rapid Haze formula.
With more tools, we can meet the unique demands of every matchup we face.
If you're ready for the next step, look no further.
Wait, do I...
Do I do the advanced build?
Or the normal build?
The one that has Ricochet?
Super early game.
The fuck does this mean?
Okay.
Yeah, let's do the...
Let's do the normal one.
Yeah, I'm like...
It's like...
Frequency Seize.
Tanks and lead to spirit damage.
I'm like...
The fuck does lead to...
What the fuck is...
Alright, we're gonna do the normal one.
It has Ricochet here.
The normal one.
The normal one sounds good.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, yeah!
The lifesteal.
That's why Haze is really good.
I heard about it.
Maybe we just play...
Look, maybe I'm just as good as...
Just as good as Haze!
As Abrams!
You don't know that!
I could be just as...
The Sniper Lady was just not for me!
We learned!
We learned that I can't be the Sniper Lady because all I do is shoot people instead of farming.
Like, when they give me a Sniper, all I wanna do is shoot the person and not the creeps.
And then when I was playing Abrams, I had... I could punch the creeps, so like...
So like, I was willing to farm more.
This time it'll be different!
Guys, this time!
This time I'll definitely...
I'll definitely farm, I swear to God.
This time!
It'll be so different, chat, I swear.
I'll learn how to farm now, I swear to God.
I learned!
I learned how to farm now!
I swear!
This'll be so easy.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
Uh...
Alright.
Okay, we're never touching her again.
We never!
Okay.
I don't know what else to do after that.
I don't know.
I have to pick one more.
Okay, I guess I'll...
I guess I'll put her in there just in case.
Name!
Thank you for... Welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Okay.
Sorry, I'm messing.
Alright, enter queue.
This is it.
We'll be fine.
I swear to God.
Okay, I guess we're just meant to be Abrams.
I...
I guess...
I guess... Wait!
We don't even have...
Wait, how come I don't get him?!
What?!
None of you are even playing Haze!
Oh, you're playing Haze!
Oh, we can't have a mirror match!
Oh!
Am I solo-lady?
When will I have friends?
When the fu- This is fucked.
This is so fucked.
Oh my God.
Okay, it's fine.
I don't need...
I don't need... I do not need another person to lane with me.
No, the thing is, is that, like, whoever you're laning with, it's randomized.
I think.
Because sometimes you get nobody, and sometimes you do, and it's so fucked.
Like, I'm just that unlucky.
I'm literally just that unlucky when it comes to, like, nobody... no people.
Nobody laning.
Like, literally.
I'm just that unlucky.
I don't know how.
I legitimately don't know how I'm so unlucky when it comes to that.
What the fuck?
Learn how to aim.
Like...
Like, holy shit.
Oh my god.
...
Nice.
Oh, shit!
I'm fucking... I'm sorry!
I wasn't paying attention after that!
I thought I was so funny!
I wasn't paying attention because he fucking died so fast.
I... bro... bro... I told you noobs don't know how to parry!
It was pretty funny though.
I was not paying attention to my HP right after.
Noobs just don't know how to parry.
What can I say?
What can I fucking say?
Alright, let's go back in.
Let's go back in.
I'm coming back.
Oh, that's fucking right.
Oh, you thought you can...
You thought you can just be here?
You thought you can just be over here?
Where did he go?
Take a nap, kid.
Alright.
That guy is bad.
That fucking...
Thank god.
Thank god he's bad.
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god, dude.
That's great.
I need that.
I fucking needed that.
I'm farming him, I need that, dude!
That's fine.
I'm farming.
Stay in my lane!
That's fucking right!
Okay, he's almost dead.
Nice.
See, it's that easy.
I should upgrade.
I should upgrade!
Oh, he's back!
Hey there!
Hey!
Oh, he's so lucky!
He's so lucky!
Oh, man.
You're so lucky.
I need to go shopping.
Okay.
Thanks for the money.
Alright, nice.
Poor guy.
Thank God.
I'm so happy.
This is what I mean!
When he doesn't know how to jump, it's so easy!
I had the most...
I swear.
I told you guys.
I had the most fucking unlucky matchup before.
Now it's fine.
Now this matchup is okay.
Now let's help this guy.
This guy is the one that took the haze from me.
I fucking hate him.
He took my haze.
I fucking take your life.
Oh, you're so lucky.
Oh, my God.
I was gonna take your life for taking my fucking...
For taking...
For taking the haze.
I wanted to play haze.
Oh, he's back!
The baby's back.
I'm coming over, baby.
Oh, you're back.
Oh, don't worry.
Oh, I'm heading over.
I'm heading over, little baby.
I'm heading over.
That's right.
Let's go!
Where did you go?
It's fine.
You can have it.
I don't care.
You can fucking have it.
He deserves it.
He needs it.
No, he fucking needs it more than me.
Like, he thinks I care?
That little baby deserved it.
Alright, nice.
Can I get this now?
Nice.
Okay.
We're fine.
Stop!
I deserve this!
What do you mean?
After everything I've been through!
I deserve this!
Give it to me!
Oh, he's back.
That's fine.
Is the baby coming over?
Really?
Oh my god, you saw that?
Yeah!
You saw that?
He's bad.
That's good.
I'm glad you saw that.
Not enough for the best gear.
What is he doing?
Fucking watch this guy!
Look at this guy!
Oh shit.
Got hit there.
What the fuck?
I got hit!
Okay.
Oh shit.
Goodbye.
Oh my god.
Another teammate showed up to help.
That's illegal.
That's actually illegal.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe he showed up.
Alright.
It's fine.
Yay!
We got a shot now.
I can't believe it.
He's gotta learn!
He's gotta learn about the matchup!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh!
He's back.
I'm getting over.
He's...
Zoom!
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
I had to zoom.
No.
You don't understand.
It was very important for me to do that.
I had to zoom.
I needed to kill him first.
Guys.
You don't understand.
I had to kill him first.
I had to.
I needed that farm.
You don't understand.
I really needed that farm, guys.
Punch.
Alright.
Off we go.
You can't learn like this.
Well, I had to learn like this!
If I had to learn like this, so does he!
Sorry!
Sink or swim!
If I had to learn like this, they have to learn like this too!
Disgusting!
Let's just be like that!
Come on!
Whoa!
Guys, I'm an Abramein!
I'm an Abramein!
Watch this!
He's too scared to move!
He's so scared!
He's too scared!
Come on!
Get over here!
Get over here, little guy!
Come on!
Get over here!
Awwww!
Aww!
I'll go help my team!
I'll let this little baby go!
I'll let the little baby go!
Come on!
Get over there, baby!
Wait,
wait!
Where is she?
Get back out here, baby!
Wait, what happened?
You're kicking his ass.
Oh shit!
He's coming back!
He's back, guys!
Guys, he's back!
Guys, the child is back!
Where are you, child?
That's right!
I'm coming!
Oh, you think you can run?
You can't run from me!
You think you can run?
Nice, alright.
We got the child.
We got the child!
We just had to get him.
That's really it.
Mission traumatized the child!
If I had to go through the torture of playing this game not knowing what the fuck I was doing...
He does too.
I'm coming over!
Oh, you think you can run?
Oh, shit!
Okay, never mind.
Child came back to help his teammate.
She had been traumatized too, so he knows how it feels.
Oh, you think...
Okay, where are you?
Where's sad lady?
Sad lady!
Your fucking friend farmed...
Let me farm them!
They did this.
Alright, I'll come back and help.
Alright.
Nice.
Farm heroes, not minions!
I'm so tanky now.
All I'm saying is that this was all because of that baby.
Oh, baby's back!
Baby's back!
Don't worry.
I will go back, but let me kill this one guy first.
Hey!
I'm coming over!
Hey there, child!
Hey!
Yes!
Wait, where did you go?
Okay.
Alright, now I need to buy items.
Run, baby!
Get out of there!
Alright.
Oh, he left.
My first rage quit, let's go!
Let's fucking go!
He actually quit!
Holy fuck!
He quit the game!
Let's fucking go!
Okay, now I see why people like MOBAs.
Now...
Look what you did!
What happened?
Doki!
What the fuck happened?
Wait, who did this to you?
You don't understand.
This was me when I first tried to play this game.
This was literally me.
You don't understand.
I had to do this too.
That's fucking right.
It's time to punch.
Where is he?
Oh!
Oh, I don't care!
I will kill you!
Oh my god.
Nice, I got the kill.
I got the kill, guys.
That's all that matters.
Where is the sniper?
Where is the sniper girl?
Where is she?
You don't understand.
I went through so much today.
I went through...
I don't even care about the sniper lady.
I'll fucking kill her first.
Oh, you think you can get out of here?
You think you can snipe and be on the ground?
Where are you?
Where the fuck...
Oh, hey there!
Hey!
Hey there!
Where did you go?
Get over here!
Get your ass over here!
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Oh hey, I got a staircase too.
Alright, so I made...
I made somebody plug for the first time.
That felt good.
That...
That felt...
Nice.
I actually made somebody plug, guys.
Two tower shots.
It do be like that.
It's fine.
I'm not scared.
I feel so strong now.
I feel so powerful.
It's fine.
I...
Are you powerful to yourself?
Absolutely.
I am so fucking proud of myself.
You don't understand.
A monster was just born.
Thank you, Abrams.
Thank you, Surefour.
Thank you for showing me the way.
Alright, I gotta buy new items.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for showing me the way.
One I figured...
Once I found out what my actual hero was.
It was so over...
It...
It was so over.
I figured out my characters.
Who needs Haze at this point.
Who the fuck needs Haze?
Guys, all I need is just a punch.
What have you done?
Alright.
Zoom.
I don't even care about these small-ass minions.
Oh, I see you.
I see you.
Hey.
Hey there, little guy.
You think your little fire can stop me?
Yeah?
Oh, you got a friend?
Wait, what the fuck?
Yeah, was that your...
Was it worth it?
That's right.
You thought your little friend could help you.
Too bad.
Poor guys.
Poor little guys.
You thought his friend was gonna save him.
You took the haze away from me.
You took haze away from me and I will take your life now.
There you go.
It's causing other people misery.
She took haze away.
I wanted to play haze.
Please.
And now I shall cause terror.
She did a favor taking haze away.
But I wanted to learn a new character.
What am I getting hit by?
Like, what the fuck was that?
Alright.
It's fine.
I gotta reload.
Punch.
Oh, wait.
He's throwing me a punch.
There we go.
Hey, get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Get your...
No.
Oh, no!
No!
That's so many people!
Help!
They're getting up on me!
They learned!
Okay.
That's fine.
I escaped.
Oh, thank God.
I almost... That was close.
That was close.
That was like four of them.
They had to get all four of them together to fucking kill me.
That was scary.
Oh, wait.
I don't want that actually.
Destroy it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They had to get all four of them just to... just to take me down.
But that's okay.
I'm coming back.
I'm fucking...
I'm coming back!
What?
What was that actually?
What the fuck?
No!
I got beaten!
That's fine.
You might have baited me, but I still got away, bitch.
I still got away.
It's that easy.
Movement.
Fucking movement.
Too slippery.
They're now going together in packs.
That's cheating.
If I can 1v4 all of them, they should be able to.
Like, this is actually cheating.
This is fucked up.
This is actually so fucked up.
I can't believe it.
Those losers.
They're for... they're for sacking.
Oh, the patron's transforming!
I wanna be in!
Get me in there!
Oh my god.
I can't!
It's closed!
Oh, what the fuck?
They're closed!
Let me in!
Don't worry, I'm here.
I'm here now.
I'm here for the fight.
I'm here to join the fight, guys.
Wait, where are they?
Jesus Christ, what the fuck is hitting me?
Oh, back there.
Oh, there is these guys.
What's going on?
Like, what is that do?
I don't know.
Oh, that hurts me!
Okay.
I was so confused.
Like...
Wait, what?
I got tethered!
No!
That's fucked.
That's so fucked.
I got tethered.
You gotta drop down.
You have to drop down.
You have to drop down, bitch.
You have to.
I know you do.
That's fucking right.
I knew you had to drop down.
You're not the lady I was fighting.
But I knew.
I fucking knew.
Oh, did you see that?
I killed all your friends.
That's right.
Get over here.
You have to drop down.
Get down from the sky.
Oh, you're gonna... Okay, that's fine.
I'll fucking get your base.
I'll get your base then.
Fly away, you fucking coward!
You fucking coward!
I knew it.
You think I would let you do this to me?
You have to drop down soon early.
Get down from the sky.
You fucking bitch.
The only reason is...
Where is my teammate?
Like, where are they?
We literally got it.
And we all pushed together.
Now they all respawn.
This one sniper.
I can't get the sniper lady.
She's too fucking...
She's like in the sky.
I can't fist her.
Literally the one thing I can't do.
That's literally the one thing I couldn't do because she was in the sky.
It's not fair.
It's actually not fair.
It's so not fair.
I'm gonna start fisting.
Alright.
Give me your fucking...
Okay.
I'm fucking leaving.
I know when I have to leave.
I know when I have to go.
Wait.
That's fucking...
That's right.
No!
Get down!
Get your ass down here!
I'm gonna take my anger out from this guy.
I can't fucking get you down.
I'm taking my anger out of him.
Okay.
Where are you?
Where's the sniper?
You fucker.
That's fine.
I'll take my anger out on you!
Okay.
I can't anymore.
I'm just gonna...
This lady!
Zero damage guys!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Yay!
Okay.
This guy was definitely learning the game.
Like...
Oh my God.
Their suffering ends finally.
Thank you for the five gift ships.
Thank you.
Look.
All I have to do is...
Okay.
Now!
Now I can play Haze!
Now give me Haze!
Okay.
Guys, I just wanna play Haze.
Like once.
That's all I want.
All it took was one baby and lane.
Navi!
Thank you for the five gift ships.
Thank you.
I swear to God if I don't get Haze... Yay!
I got Haze!
Let Zeki go!
All right.
Yay!
I can do Haze now!
Shooter increases your bullet damage on that target.
Gain one stack per bullet.
Two if the hit is a headshot.
Oh, okay.
And then, all right.
Buying purple account.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
Surefour told me about it too.
I just keep forgetting to buy it.
Because I just auto buy.
I just like...
I just like, you know, autopilot when I'm buying stuff.
Navi!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Good luck on your games!
Toki!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Why everyone like Haze?
Apparently she's really strong.
If she has like... if she can farm really well.
Guys, please don't... please.
I hope my MMR is still okay.
I'm sorry for understanding the game now.
I hope...
Guys, please.
Please.
Give me noobs, please.
I'm still a baby.
I swear to god.
Please.
It was just a fluke.
Abram was just a fluke.
I swear.
Please give me baby Loppy.
Why am I solo laning again?
Bro!
Are you fucking serious?
Why am I only solo laning?
This is fucking stupid.
They got seven... what was it?
Four games in a row I'm fucking solo laning.
It's not fair.
I have to shoot turrets?
Bro!
That person might as well...
Oh!
Just cause they do one?
This is not fair.
I need my solo queue.
I will have a solo queue and make friends in the game.
I can't believe it.
Solo lansers are for people with no friends.
This is fucked up.
I'm gonna report Valve.
I'm gonna send a complaint.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it.
Oh my God.
Report Valve to who?
To the federal government.
This is against my human rights.
I feel like solo queue should allow you to be able to duo lane and make friendships along the way.
It should not be given prioritized to people with friends.
It should let you be able to... Okay, let's see.
When does the farm stuff open up?
When do the triangles come up?
Competitive game only.
Why are non-solo lane reserved for people with friends?
That's all I'm saying.
They shouldn't be reserved for people with friends.
I swear to God.
You deny me my fucking farm.
I'm gonna deny you.
What?
No.
I'm farming, guys.
Are you guys proud of me?
I'm trying to farm right now.
I'm trying to farm.
Alright, that's fine.
Okay.
I'm trying my best to farm, guys.
I need to train with coordination.
Okay.
Have you ever seen a gun shooting?
I'm trying my best.
I'm farming.
Oh, God.
Okay, nice.
Headshot.
Yes.
Okay.
Our guy died already?
He
died already.
What the fuck?
What did you do?
Oh, I missed a sleep.
I'm lucky.
Nah, I missed a sleep.
I'm so stupid.
I got too overzealous there.
He has a baby.
Where's my baby?
Where's my babies?
How am I supposed to farm?
Okay, there's creeps here.
Nice.
I need to farm, you guys.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I need to go.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so baby, too.
Alright.
I need to go to the shop.
Shop, please.
Okay.
That's fine.
Yeah, but...
It's not the same punching with this lady.
Wow!
Shit!
I was not expecting her to shoot me.
Holy shit.
That scared the shit out of me.
Not gonna lie.
I was not expecting it.
I was like, what the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Where the fuck did you come from?
Oh, unlucky for me.
I might have to leave.
I need to go back.
Oh, don't.
Don't hit that.
Don't Kovacs.
Don't you dare Kovacs.
Oh, I might need to go.
I'm gonna go.
No!
No more dash!
Get over there!
Okay, thank god.
Alright.
I have to...
I have to go back.
No!
I need to farm more!
Fucking...
Okay, you're right.
Farming sucks.
I fucking hate farming.
Farming fucking sucks, guys.
HAHAHAHA.
You guys were right.
I can't believe you guys were right.
Farming is not fun.
Farming is not fun, guys.
That's fucking right.
Oh, come on.
No way, you fucker!
You fucker!
You were so low!
I was so close too.
I was gonna punch as well.
I was gonna punch!
You guys saw that?
I almost punched!
And then he ran away like a little bitch!
Bitch!
I can't believe it.
I actually was gonna punch too.
I was ready.
I was right in it.
I was so ready.
I think my team's bad.
I'm looking at the farm and the enemy team is like 1000 and then my team is like fucking not even breaking 1k.
Guys, I'm learning!
Are you proud of me?
I'm actually learning!
Holy fuck!
What happened?
Oh my god.
She's just like me when I didn't know what the fuck was going on.
The what's-her-name-the-vindicta is just like me when I was confused too.
She's just like me.
I was just like you.
Confused and wondering what the fuck was going on.
Wait, what?
What did I do?
Oh, I... that was an accident.
Whoops.
I just need... it's... he's almost... he's literally one.
Yes!
Nice, I got some farm.
That's good.
Okay.
Wait, what the fuck?
Okay, is there any... any items for me to pick up?
This is bad.
Wait, how is she like so ahead of me?
Oh, cause she left the lane.
Fucking coward!
Actual coward!
You don't just leave the lane!
You commit!
Oh god, grandpa needs help.
Don't worry, grandpa!
Don't worry, I'm gonna steal your creep too!
Hahaha!
Don't worry, grandpa!
Grandpa, I'm here!
Don't worry!
Hahaha!
Thanks, grandpa, for the creep.
Thank you.
You're welcome, grandpa.
You're...
You're welcome.
Okay.
That was a good sleep though.
I did that.
You guys see that?
Oh, I have Reaper now.
Nice.
Oh, I want this creep!
I want these!
Am I strong enough for this?
I am not strong enough.
Whoops.
JK.
Guys, I want the...
Oh, wait.
Where's the baby ones?
Wait, did he already use farm the babies?
Okay, we're sharing lanes now.
Oh shit!
I leave!
Nevermind!
I need lifesteal, you're right.
I need lifesteal.
I'm sorry!
I was so overzealous!
I was so happy!
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh, where's lifesteal?
Where is it?
Okay.
There you go.
We're at early game now, I think.
Whoa!
Lane until 10 minutes?
Is it not 10?
It's not 10.
It's not.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize it's not yet.
Whoopsie.
Guys, I don't know what's considered early game and what's considered like the right game.
Actually don't know.
I'm just buying stuff in order.
I'm literally buying stuff in order.
I'm gonna help her.
Fucking sniper lady.
Vindicta?
She's having a very rough- Oh wait, but I wanna farm this actually.
Give me.
I know how it feels, Vindicta.
I was just like you.
I was just like you, feet lady, when I was forced to play that character.
And I was so confused.
I was just like you.
Don't worry.
I know how it feels too.
I know how it feels to be so confused.
What the fuck?
How fucking tanky are they?
Oh my- Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, I didn't realize they were that tanky, guys.
I got- Oh my god.
I think I got a bug.
I think my game was like, no.
Shit.
I guess the game was like, what the fuck are you doing?
I'm sorry.
That was my bad.
I don't know why.
I don't know why I thought that was a good idea.
Oh, that was absolutely- was not a good idea at all.
Oh my god.
Nice, I got him.
Okay, that's good.
That's good the Inferno came over for me.
Thank god.
Oh, thank god.
Your ult is on me.
Yeah.
Yeah, I figured- I figured it was a 1v1 scenario after that.
I was like, it's just like Reaper.
In my head, I was like, it's just like Reaper.
All I do is just go right in and then be like, die, die, die.
And then we fucking GG's.
It was not just like Reaper, guys.
It was absolutely not just like Reaper.
What the f- Okay, that's fine.
Like, I mean, we got it.
That's all that matters, right?
We literally got it, so.
Okay, I need you guys to go in.
I need you guys to go in for me.
Because like- Because like, they're- they're doing so much damage.
Oh wait, picking up unsecured souls?
The fuck does that mean?
Oh wait.
Sleepy time!
That's fucking right!
Oh shit!
Sleepy time!
Yay!
Sleepy!
Oh, I can do it again.
Guys, this time it'll work.
This time it's gonna work, guys.
Trust me.
Wait, he doesn't know.
Guys, it- I don't know why.
This time it'll work.
Okay.
Okay, it did not work.
I thought- I thought I'd be different!
Okay.
Okay, guys, watch this.
Okay, now we know.
Now we know.
It's about sending a message chat.
I wanted to send a message, guys.
That like, I ain't afraid.
Oh shit, I'm afraid.
Oh my god, that's a lot of people.
Okay, I'm a little afraid there.
Actually, I'm a little afraid.
That's a lot.
What the fuck?
That's a lot of people over there.
Oh my god, what is he trying to do?
Oh shit, I didn't realize I was so low!
Woo!
Haha, bitch!
My teammate died!
My teammate died, but I'm okay.
Guys, it's okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, what?
Where am I?
Oh, I- whoops.
It's okay.
My teammate's dead, but it's okay.
What do I get for this, though?
I don't know.
Okay, bullet resistance?
Guys, I don't think we're- I think we're gonna lose.
I think this is my first loss.
It wasn't me though.
I'm not the problem.
I don't think I'm the problem here.
I don't think it was me.
I was definitely not the issue here.
There we go.
I was doing the best I could in that situation.
This was the third one.
Like, maybe if I...
Okay, honestly, the only thing that I think maybe I should of done differently is that maybe I should not have ulted like that.
Like...
That's the only thing I could think of differently...
No!
I can't!
I just got the cool down!
Okay, I couldn't!
I literally just- the cool down literally just showed up!
But it's not me.
I'm not the issue here.
Like I'm literally like in the right.
I'm not the problem.
I know I'm not the problem.
I literally have the smallest KDA.
I know I'm not the issue.
Okay guys.
I figured out that I am most definitely an Abram player.
After everything I went- after trying all these characters, I know who I'm like most like best for.
Oh shit!
I know which character I'm- Never leave Abram.
Yeah, I know that I cannot leave Abram.
Abram was the key.
Abram was literally the key to success.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wow, where is he?
Oh nice, okay.
Abram was the key.
Without Abram, we wouldn't win.
There's like a guy here, I think?
He was like- Where was he?
Is he lurking?
I thought I saw somebody here.
Oh well.
I don't know.
Get over here.
I'm farming!
I'm farming as fast as I could!
Oh, not that fast.
Okay.
Technically, I am not farming as fast as I could.
Guys, I am...
I was not...
Don't worry.
Now I am!
Holy shit.
That's a lot of people!
I'm fucking leaving.
I'm like...
Right!
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Don't worry, teammate!
Don't worry, Grandpa!
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Don't worry!
Whoa.
Don't worry, Grandpa!
Grandpa's dead.
I'm worrying.
Grandpa's so fucking dead, guys.
Okay.
But I wasn't the issue, at least.
At least we know it wasn't me.
He dodged it?
That's fucking cheating!
Guys, I think I might lose my first game.
I think I might...
Guys, I think it's over.
I think it's over.
Guys, we're supposed to...
I don't even have Ricochet yet.
My team is struggling.
My team is having a bad time!
And it's so understandable!
Oh, shit!
It's B-bomb time!
That's fucking right.
I learned about sleep.
That's fucking right!
I learned about how to do it!
It worked!
Guys, it's fine.
Even if we lose, we made our first successful...
Our very first...
Our very first ult, guys.
That's all that matters.
We got our very first ult.
That's literally all that matters.
Oh my god.
Please, I need Ricochet.
Please!
That's literally the only reason to play her apparently.
But I can't even afford it!
I can't even afford it!
I'm so poor!
Oh my god.
Where did she go?
She fucking... Okay.
That's not fair.
That is also not fair.
Wow!
Goodbye!
Ah!
Hahaha!
At least you learned.
We didn't farm enough!
We weren't even the worst farmers in our team!
Oh my god.
I'm so... I don't even... I'm not even close!
I'm not...
Good job finding the enemy team.
Guys, I think it's over.
I think there was definitely a dead weight and it's not There's a dead weight here.
And I know for sure it was not me.
I know for sure.
It's...
There's no way it's high elo!
Look at the splice!
I missed...
I missed the baby.
No wonder people in League always smurf.
Makes so much more sense now.
Now I understand why people smurf in this game.
Now I understand.
There we go.
Oh shit!
Did you guys see that?
I got the...
I got the fucking...
Sleep on that.
That shit was crazy.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Oh, I missed this leap.
It's okay, I got you guys!
I got...
Oh, god.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
You guys were so...
You guys are so fucked.
There was nothing for me to do.
You guys were fucked out of the way.
The best I can do is fucking flank from behind.
Wow!
That's fine.
Do I have enough?
No, I don't.
That's fine.
Oh, she's so low.
Come on.
She's so low.
Punch her!
Wait, where did she go?
Oh, there she is.
Oh, I can do it!
Finally, Ricochet!
It's over, but like...
At least I can buy Ricochet.
Where do I buy...
Put Ricochet on?
Chat.
Guys, where do I put Ricochet on?
Where do I do it?
Oh, wait.
Where do I... Which one do I get rid of?
Which one do I get rid of?
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
It's over.
We figured it out.
We figured out the game plan here.
This is it.
It's so over.
We have...
We have Ricochet.
Oh my god!
It's so over.
It's so over for you.
It's so over!
That's great.
It's so over for you.
It's literally so over.
I have the ultimate
Can't do anything about it.
That's fucking right.
You fucker.
You think I don't know?
You think I don't know, buddy?
Oh my god.
It's over.
It's so over for her.
It's actually so over.
Okay.
We just gotta keep farming.
Nerf incoming.
The moment I figured out about Ricochet.
We're in it.
We're so in it.
It's not even funny.
Holy shit!
That DPS should not be legal.
Actually.
That is crazy DPS right there.
That DPS is insane.
That is actually insane.
Oh my god.
What the f...
Where is she?
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
What did she do?
What was that?
What the fuck?
What do I do for this?
I don't know what to put.
Improve reach.
Do I put it on?
Oh, I guess that's the only one.
Oh my god.
She swung her HP.
Guys, it's over.
I got Ricochet too late.
I can't...
I got baited so hard.
Oh my god.
I got baited so fucking hard by that.
That's crazy.
I can't...
Guys, I'm sorry.
I can't help but melee.
It's... after playing Abrams, it's like...
It's just second nature, you know?
It's literally second nature for me.
Okay, here we go.
It's literally everything I can do.
right now.
Oh my god.
It's so...
My team is...
My team is not doing so well right now.
I accidentally fell in.
I fell in accidentally.
Oh no.
My...
That was an accident.
No.
I got stunned.
That's fine.
That's so fine.
I got the farm.
That's okay.
Literally.
Just keep Ricochet.
Yes!
Okay.
Do I have enough?
Do I have enough for Leech, guys?
I don't know.
I'm just trying...
I'm just trying to make sure...
I'm just trying to make sure my team is okay.
That's really it.
We fend them off for another day.
We were able to fend them off another day.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
No, my team!
Team, are you guys okay?
Are you guys okay?
Be strong!
You guys got this!
Be strong, everybody!
We can do it!
Oh, you think I don't know?
You think I'm...
Good side.
You think I'm not used to this?
You think...
Oh, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
Oh, I can buy it!
I can buy Leech!
Oh my god, it's time!
Alright.
Alright, where's Leech?
Which one's Leech?
Where is it?
Guys, where is Leech?
Guys!
Guys, please!
Oh, wait.
Leech.
Which one is it?
Oh, here you go!
There it is!
What do I get rid of?
Guys, which one do I get rid of?
Which one?
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I know, like, people needed me and I was too busy trying to figure out how to how to buy stuff.
Because I know...
Okay.
I'm so sorry.
I know you guys need my help.
I was so busy buying stuff.
Oh, he fucking ran.
Like a little bitch boy.
You think I don't know?
I don't know you're right here.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you think...
Oh, I'm not scared of you.
Wait.
I'm not scared of you.
Wait a minute.
I'm not scared of you at all.
You're so weak.
Why should I be scared of you?
Okay.
Why did I steal?
Why did I need... oh!
Wait.
This is good.
A rejuvenator.
This?
Oh, I gotta help.
I gotta help.
Wait, they do?
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
They got... I didn't even realize!
I didn't even realize!
I didn't even realize they were doing the rejuvenating shit!
Oh no!
No!
What?!
Oh god!
Oh I can't even!
I can't even get out!
No.
Oh no.
I'm still alive.
I can't move but...
No!
It's over.
We had a good run.
Guys, I just got the lifesteal.
I don't know how to work with it.
I didn't know.
This is my first time with a lifesteal.
Nice team death.
Guys, wait.
I think...
Guys, I can make it.
Guys, I can make it work.
Guys, I can...
I can make this work.
I can make Haze work, guys.
Guys, I can...
Now that I realize...
Now that I realize how to play Haze...
I can make it work, guys.
I swear to god.
Oh no, there's an Abram.
No, I have to fight an Abram?
No!
I don't know how good Abram is!
I...
No!
I hate this game.
Oh, there's two of us!
Oh my god, I have a friend!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go.
I have a friend.
Okay, but now...
Now I know how...
Now I just need to know...
Now I just know how to do the build.
It'll be fine.
We figured it out, guys.
We figured it out.
Like, we know how to play this...
We know how to play Haze now.
Oh my god, we know how to play Haze.
Because I'm not addicted.
I just...
I just know how to play Haze now.
Okay.
I need to make sure, like, I don't get distracted.
I just need to make sure...
Bro, what the fuck?
Get away from me!
Okay, that's fine.
I'm okay.
Where's the shop?
The moment I get out of the stupid...
Oh, I don't have anything.
The moment I get out of the stupid lane part of the game...
Like, things actually work.
The only issue is that...
The lane part of this game is very long.
And I don't have the patience for it sometimes.
That's the worst part.
No.
No, not Abram.
Not Abram.
No!
Get away!
Why is my teammate not looking at him?
Teammate, please!
I almost died!
I'm leaving.
I need a heal.
Maybe having a friend fucking sucks.
It's not fun.
I'd rather be in the solo lane now.
My teammate is not...
My teammate is not fucking helpful.
I've decided.
I should have been in the solo lane all along.
I realized my mistakes.
I realized my mistakes thinking that I would enjoy having a friend.
They were wrong.
Okay, I gotta sleep.
Come on!
Peek your head!
I'm gonna steal your creep too.
I'm gonna steal your fucking creep.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Pushing out the A.
The cow, they're juggling.
Nice.
Reload.
Oh hey, he's back.
Wait, he's back.
Wait a minute, he's back.
Wait a minute.
Oh, he's back too!
Oh no, b-bop!
Not b-bop.
Wait, they swapped lanes.
They literally swapped.
That's illegal.
When you have your friend, you gotta be friends forever.
That's not true.
People change.
But it's still... that's so... that's so dumb.
I can't believe it.
I'm gonna buy stuff.
That's illegal!
They literally swapped lanes!
Oh shit.
Oh no, oh no.
I'm trying to help you.
I'm trying to help you!
He ran off!
Like a little bitch!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, okay.
Almost got too early there.
That was close.
That was actually close.
That's fine.
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
Boom!
No!
I'm sorry!
Why?
Why does she keep doing...
Why does she keep leaving me?
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, I should've gotten life steer.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
I don't do anything in order.
Anyway.
It's okay.
Wait, where were we?
We were in blue, right?
Guys, I lost track of my color.
Was I in blue?
Wrong lane?
Yeah, okay.
I was in blue.
Okay.
Guys, it wasn't the wrong lane.
I did this on purpose so I can grab some stuff here.
Look at that.
Now I have extra stuff.
How do I get out of here?
Okay.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, friend.
I got you.
I never leave you.
Don't worry.
See?
We did it.
We helped.
Teamwork.
Are you serious?
I got...
Please.
Please, look at me!
Oh, no!
Look!
Next time.
Holy shit.
I feel like I got baited like three times, but I swear to God, I feel like I got baited so many times.
Are you serious?
Holy shit.
Okay.
I baited myself.
Oh, no.
Maybe.
True.
Maybe I did.
Wait.
Am I...
Is my friend dead?
Oh, she's dead.
No, she's not.
Okay.
Snap time.
Oh, it's not the wrong person.
True.
Maybe I was...
I think I was the problem.
Actually, I would not be surprised if I was.
No.
You're right.
I'm the problem.
No.
You're 100% right.
You're right.
I'm like the cocky DPS player.
I am 100% that cocky DPS player right there.
He's so low.
He's actually so low.
Fuck.
No.
I'm so mad.
He was so low.
Okay.
That's fine.
It was fine.
He was so close.
What?
Cancel it.
Oh, there it is.
We were actually so close.
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
It's so not fair.
That was so not fair.
We deserved that.
Bitch.
You actual bitch.
No.
He did the thing.
He knows.
He fucking knows.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
No.
Come on.
I need to reload.
Nice.
We did it.
Together.
Oh.
I should have ulted.
I keep forgetting I have ult.
It's okay.
It's a learning experience.
I keep forgetting my abilities.
It's okay.
It's all a learning experience.
Guys.
Okay.
Do I need to buy stuff?
Yeah.
Goodbye.
Goodbye my fellow teammate.
Uh.
Sure.
Let's go.
Rush.
Ricochet.
I forgot.
Boom.
Ricochet.
Guys.
I forgot all about.
Oh.
No.
Oh my God.
I can't believe I forgot about Ricochet.
The most important thing.
Okay.
That's fine.
I mean.
It's fine.
Give me this.
Give me this!
I need my ricochet!
Oh, we have a DC.
No!
Not the DC!
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
We can turn it around!
We can totally turn it around!
My buddy and I are still in it together!
Me and my buddy!
What do I need for ricochet anyway?
Upgrade my abilities?
Whoops.
Whoa.
I was not paying attention when that happened.
Okay.
6,000.
That's fine.
We're almost there.
We're so close.
We're so close to 6,000.
Wait.
Where's my buddy?
Where's my friend?
Where is she?
No!
Where's my friend?
Where is she?
I don't know how to play this without her!
People change.
No!
People change!
I thought we were going to be in this together forever!
I can't believe he would leave me like that.
I'm so sad.
I thought we would be doing this for the rest of our lives.
I...
I thought we would be doing this for the rest of our existence here!
I thought we meant something!
Did we not?
Life is not so dorky anymore.
No!
Oh, I fucking missed it.
I missed.
It's okay.
I got this though.
That's fine.
We're almost at Ricochet!
We almost have it!
Okay.
Nice.
Wait.
What happened to the big guy?
Anyway.
Upgrade skill.
I won't stop until they're dead.
Okay.
Wait, did they do it?
Oh, they did.
Nice.
You only have one shrine left.
Wait.
Whoa!
That's where they all are!
Oh
my god!
I was like, you only have one shrine left!
I was like, excuse me?
Like...
And they're...
Wait, what the fuck happened?
Like, what the fuck?
Actually, what the fuck happened?
Like, what the...
Holy shit!
Okay, everything is fine now.
Everything is fine now.
Okay.
All right.
Ricochet.
There we go.
How much is leech?
Leech.
Okay.
6,000 too.
This is fine.
Okay.
Now...
Now it's fine.
Same price.
Okay.
This is okay.
We figured it out.
Holy shit.
I was like wondering.
I was like, what?
What do you mean one shrine left?
Like, how?
How do we have one left?
No.
Turin lady.
No!
No.
No, I might be dead though.
Whoa!
That's fucking right.
It's nap time, bitch.
Okay, we're okay.
We got nap time out of the way.
Oh, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm always paranoid vaulting ever since I, ever since I threw it.
What the fuck?
No, no, no, no, nope.
Nope.
Where am I?
That's fucking right.
Get your baited ass out of here!
Get baited, bitch.
Get fucking baited.
I need this farm.
I need this farm so bad.
Alright, nice.
We're almost at 6.2.
Oh, played.
See, this is the fun part.
The fun part of Deadlock when I'm not in the stupid lane.
Whatever.
This is literally the only time I can have fun in this game.
Play.
Nice.
Okay.
Where are they fighting?
I'm trying to, like, figure out where to go.
I'm trying...
I'll just get rid of all of these for now.
Punch.
Alright.
I'm so close!
Please!
I literally am so close!
Oh, we got help.
Getting lost is the true enemy.
Honestly, yeah.
I'm literally just getting lost in this entire game.
Oh, is he gonna push?
He's not?
Oh, interesting.
Oh.
That's fine.
That's fine, get baited.
I'm okay with that.
Nice.
How do you get lost with a ma- oh.
Yeah.
That's a very good question.
That's a very good question, guys.
You just get lost.
You see, when I play any game, it just happens.
Okay, now I will never run away.
I ain't afraid no more.
That's fucking right.
I'm not afraid anymore!
What the fuck?
What did she do?
Think I'm scared of you?
Yes!
Okay.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did he go?
I'm so- Oh, we're chasing.
Okay.
Alright.
But like, what if that's an item?
Wait, there's- There's somebody here.
Abram.
I know you don't have it no more!
That's right.
Worth.
100%.
I know he didn't have it anymore, so I went for it.
I went full YOLO on that.
That gamble was so worth it.
That was such a worth gamble.
That's fine.
Whoa, wait.
Wait, there's people here.
That's right.
Let me life steal.
That's fucking right.
Go to sleep.
Go to sleep!
I'm unstoppable!
Oh fuck, wait.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Please unlock the door.
Unlock!
Unlock now!
That's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is- Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
Everything is so healthy.
It's not like I have leech.
I'm healthy.
Oh shit!
Wait, I see an Abram.
I see an Abram!
Hey there, Abram!
Heeey!
Oh shit, okay.
Oh shit.
OH SHIT!!
Oh my god.
He brought a friend.
I wouldn't have been scared if he didn't bring Bring his fucking friend, chat!
Look guys, if he didn't bring his friend, it would have been fine.
I would have been a-okay.
Alright, let's see.
Alright, nice.
I want to go all the way back.
That's right, you ain't no tank no more.
Get lucky shot?
Alright, what does it say?
What do I need?
Okay, builds.
I guess I'll get improved reach.
Wait, what do we imbue-oh, uh...
What do we get, actually?
Unstoppable?
Sure.
Might as well.
Now nobody can stop me.
What does unstoppable do?
I didn't read, by the way, so...
I would like to know what it does because I didn't pay attention.
Wait!
What?
Why are you firing-what?
Okay, I literally just got back.
Okay.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Oh no, oh no.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
What are you doing, man?
What?
What are you doing?
Why are you running?
Alright, there we go.
We're fine.
Wait!
Is she back?
Oh!
Nice, alright.
Okay, we did it.
We saved it.
We did it, everybody!
Yay!
We saved the day!
We fucking did it!
Holy fuck!
That was close.
Alright, little guys.
Go do your thing, little guys.
That's right.
Holy shit!
I'm fucking shredding!
I'm fucking insane!
Oh no.
I saw the ice beam.
I knew my time was over.
Oh my god!
Okay.
That's fine.
So you didn't chase me?
Oh, he knows.
He knows.
He doesn't want to chase me no more.
He...
He fucking...
He knows.
He knows my shot.
I did that shot, like, twenty times on him.
He doesn't want to do that again.
He likes...
He knows what I like to do.
But...
Umm...
Good try.
Good try, guys.
Oh, yeah?
That's fucking right.
Get over here!
We're here!
Yeah!
Oh!
Okay, that was a little overkill.
But it's okay.
That was a little overkill.
But that's okay.
Jesus Christ, this game is so long.
Okay, we just got it.
Oh hey, there's an urn.
Oh hey.
Might as well, right?
How do I... how do I get this urn?
How do I... what?
Is it just here?
How do I...
How do I get this urn?
Oh, it's not there yet.
Are you serious?
Who keeps coming back to the base?
Every time!
Every fucking time!
Did he get him?
Okay, he got him.
Every... do I need to protect the base?
I feel like every time I leave the base, something happens!
Okay, late game.
What is this?
Superior stamina?
Enduring speed?
Let's go.
I mean, I have so much money now.
Oh, lucky shot?
No!
Okay, how much is lucky shot?
How much is lucky shot?
6.2?
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna go over here to help.
Oh wait, they have the... oh no!
Wait, they... that's not good.
That's not good.
Don't worry, I'm heading over.
Okay.
I'll get the urn.
Don't worry, I got the urn!
I don't, but like...
Don't worry, I'm here.
It's okay!
We got it!
Wait, who has the spirit urn?
Who has it?
Oh, here it is.
I got it.
I'm so fast.
I'm so fucking fast.
I put all my buff on speed.
That's fucking right.
Zoom!
I don't know where it is, but zoom!
Where do I drop it off?
Oh, there it is.
I'm so fucking fast.
Nice.
I didn't even have to dash.
Let's go.
I literally had to...
I literally just had all my buffs on speed, so it worked out.
It actually worked out.
That's crazy.
It's okay.
We don't need the orbs yet.
Let's get it.
Okay.
This little merry-go-round is a little stupid.
No, our base is okay!
Oh, god.
Oh.
Wait, what?
Oh, no.
Zoom!
Where is he?
Oh, you think...
You think I'm gonna let you do that?
That's fucking right.
Let's get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Get your...
Oh, shit.
There we go.
That's fucking right.
Why does no one defend base?
Why is it always me?
Why am I always the one defending the base?
I literally have the highest DPS.
No!
Please, this game is so lag.
This game has been going on forever.
Please.
Oh, my god.
I will kill you.
My lucky shot.
Oh, I can afford lucky shot now.
Okay.
Lucky shot.
Lucky...
This one.
Alright.
Okay, there we go.
We gotta push hard.
I'm heading over.
I'm heading over as fast as I can.
I swear to god.
I feel like...
I feel like no... Someone's just flanking into the base and I always have to be the one to defend the base.
Every time.
I swear to fucking god.
There we go!
We did it!
It was nearly that easy!
It was that easy.
Here we go.
Alright, here we go.
This should work, right?
Yeah, nice.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
This is fine.
So
much!
That's fine.
This is fine.
Oh, grab that.
We're not fine!
Okay, guys.
What the fuck is my DPS?
Holy shit!
What the fuck is wrong with my build?
Oh my god!
This is actually...
Oh no, now they're gonna hard push.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Perry makes it so that the...
Abrams can't do jack shit.
Oh no.
It's okay, I'm coming back.
It's okay.
It's okay, I'm here already.
We're so okay, guys.
We're here.
We're here to defend.
We can defend this, don't worry.
We just gotta figure out where they're gonna come from.
This has been a 31 minute game.
Oh no, there's the Abrams.
I see you.
I see the Abrams.
I will fight the Abrams to the last breath.
I will fight you to the last breath.
Oh no.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna go help my team now.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh shit.
I felt like I just got stopped.
Right there.
I parried.
Guys, did you see that?
I actually parried.
Holy shit.
Bro, I actually parried there.
She did it.
Holy fuck.
Okay, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Okay, we gotta push now.
I swear to god.
If you guys don't push after that, I swear the fuck you got.
I'm learning.
Our guy's going in.
I swear to god.
Come on.
I'm going there as fast as I can.
Okay.
I'm in.
Now it's asleep.
It's not gonna do anything, but it's asleep now.
It doesn't do anything, but it's asleep.
We did it.
Oh my god.
Finally.
I swear.
I was gonna fucking play this game forever.
This one game.
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck is this build?
This is so stupid.
That's LG.
That was a good game to end it on.
Oh my god.
25.
I told you I didn't need my friend.
I literally could solo carry this team.
Nexi, thank you for the five gift chips.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I swear.
This is the only thing I didn't like about Deadlock.
Is that the games are just so long.
It's just...
It's so long.
I'm not an Abrams one trick.
I'm an ace Abrams two trick.
The unstoppable with y'all was pretty good.
That was actually pretty nasty.
I chased the Abrams away so he couldn't counter me.
Nerd Bryce was really good.
Not one trick.
Let's go.
Oh.
Also.
Thank you for the super sticker.
Thank you.
Thank you for the five gift chips.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I'm going to swap over now.
How do I like Deadlock?
I'm in literally noob lobby.
I can't really give my opinion so far.
On Deadlock.
That was LG.
I'm sorry.
That was LG for me.
But...
I can't really give my opinion so far.
I think honestly...
It's because I'm in low elo.
It's not as tilting as in high elo.
Because when I play with my friends, my friends are high elo and I don't know what I'm doing.
That's what tilts me.
Because you know...
People...
The MMR is harder.
But in this MMR, it's fun because I can aim.
Like...
I can...
I have reaction time.
I have reaction time and aim skills from other FPS games.
So like...
It's easier for me to adapt by just pure aim.
And like...
And stuff.
And...
And just comboing and stuff.
So that's what's currently carrying me at the moment.
The transferable skills.
It is fun in the lower elo.
I think the higher elo you go...
Because the higher elo I was when I was playing with my friends, I was so frustrated.
I was so fucking frustrated in the higher elo.
But in this elo and just fucking around, it was really fun.
I know I'm not the... what's her name?
The feet girl?
I was definitely not that.
I was more of a Haze and Abram player.
It gets really sweaty really fast.
But I wish matches had a fixed time.
Yeah, me too.
The lane part...
The lane part is where I go crazy.
Because the lane part is where the MOBA aspect is.
That's where you get the MOBA feeling.
And then when you're out of the lane phase...
Because you guys were telling me...
Toki, you're not supposed to get out the lane yet.
You're supposed to wait until the first 10 minutes.
What are you doing?
Why are you roaming?
But I don't want to...
I don't want to lane anymore.
I'm just like...
I just want to...
I just want to walk around.
I know.
Because that's the...
That's like the MOBA part.
And like my...
My patience gets me.
My patience in the first 10 minutes is where I go crazy.
I go fucking crazy.
Because you guys saw me pushing in so many times.
I think my partner there got so frustrated at me trying to solo push two players by myself.
That she swapped lanes.
I think that's why she swapped lanes.
Because I was like, where did she go?
Why did my partner left me?
And I think it's because I kept...
I kept trying to push.
But I'm like so squishy.
And then she left.
And then she left my lane.
Because she got fucking tired of me.
But yeah.
Honestly.
I don't...
I personally don't like the...
The prep...
I personally just don't like the lane part.
I know that's like the most...
The most important part.
In a MOBA.
But it's just so... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
But then when you get your build, it's worth it.
When you...
When you become a fucking god.
It's worth it.
It's just...
I have to have the patience.
To fucking...
To become a god.
A god.
Yeah.
Did you not see me fucking become...
Unstoppable?
Unstoppable with my ult.
And I killed like...
4 plus players from that.
That shit was fucking crazy.
I chased away the Abram because he saw me.
And then I chased him away.
And then I fucking...
Now that I know I can't get ult cancelled.
I ulted him.
As soon as Doki learns how to wait 10 minutes, it's over.
She achieved godhood.
And then I parried him too.
Anyway.
That's how I feel currently.
But yeah.
I feel like it's definitely when you understand the game.
When you understand it, it does get more fun.
I'm sure.
When he gave me the quick crash course.
On two specific characters.
He tried to teach me two specific characters.
Because he's like, I think you'll like these two characters.
It definitely got more fun for me.
Because I understood the combos.
And everything.
And how to actually sort of play the game.
But not really.
Because you guys are like, please start farming creeps.
But I was farming players.
Like...
The majority.
The majority of my farm.
Was the players themselves.
Not from the actual creeps.
Because I was like.
I was like, no!
I want to farm the players.
Yeah.
You guys helping with backseating helped a lot too.
We're not playing.
We're not.
Vindicto is not it.
Please thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Peak strategy is to play as Ivy.
Use your ability to fly and throw your teammate directly into a 7.
Alt then post in chat.
What the fuck are you doing?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope you guys enjoyed watching that.
Watching the game.
Because I know it does get a little boring to watch.
When you're just trying to fucking become a guy.
Like.
When you're.
When you're trying to become a guy.
It's where it gets like.
We're like, what the fuck do we do?
So I hope you guys still had fun watching.
Yeah, I made someone rage quit.
Look.
All I'm saying is that.
When I got into the closed beta.
When Deadlock had no name.
That was me.
And you know what was worse?
They were not regular players.
They were streamers.
So I got.
I was that guy.
And then the person that was me.
Farming that baby.
Was Dyrus.
And Surefort.
Dyrus and Surefort.
Just hardtuttled me.
On my very first game.
And that is a lot worse.
Because I actually couldn't plug.
Because I was in a stream.
Streamer lobby.
So I couldn't leave.
I was in a full on.
Streamer content creator.
Lobby.
But I couldn't leave.
And it was my first game.
And they all have already played.
For like weeks already.
So.
That baby.
Deserved it.
If I.
Had to do that.
If I had to live through that.
He had to live through that.
I think that's called.
Karma.
So I continued.
The cycle.
The cycle continues.
I paid it forward.
Exactly.
I was paying it forward.
Hahaha.
Um.
Yeah.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
Everybody.
I'm going to take a break now.
Rest my voice today.
This week has been a long week of streaming.
I am going to rest up now.
As always.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.